The Joe Rogan experience.
The thing that I keep going back to is like, at the end of the
day, my head on my pillow, do I feel good about the choices I'm making?
And do I stand strong in my beliefs? Yes.
Then I'm not going to let what someone in
Idaho has to say about what I'm doing today.
Well.
People want absolutes, right?
Whether it comes to recovery from drugs and alcohol or whether it comes from
anything, they D they don't want you to deviate from the path.
And they want you to always be helpless in the face of your addictions.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> right. This is the,
this is the thought process between a lot of the 12 step program that you're
helpless in the face of your addictions. Um, I don't know if that's true.
I have never had a drug or an alcohol addiction.
I've never had that kind of a compulsion. So I don't know.
But what I read about you is that you think of yourself now as
California sober mm-hmm <affirmative> like,
please tell me what the California says.
What was that? I saw the smile on your face, like start to form.
And it just made me so happy. <laugh> all right. Well,
so a part of my, um, process now is like not
defining the parameters publicly,
because I don't feel like it's anybody's business, me and my treatment team,
but it's a term that a lot of people use, uh,
to identify this path of moderation
with the help of some green plants. Mm-hmm <affirmative>,
you know what I'm saying? I do.
And so green is the key <affirmative> mm-hmm <affirmative> and,
and that's, that's that.
<Laugh>. Yeah, but it's,
it's such a loaded subject that even bringing it up,
you have to kind of guard yourself from the way other people are gonna perceive
what you're doing. Right.
I'm a celebrity. And I guard everything. I say,
even if I'm speaking my truth,
I still have to guard it to some degree because I don't,
I I'm working so hard not to offend anyone, you know?
So it's like, yes, but every aspect of my life is that way. Now.
Now,
do you find that this green stuff makes you more relaxed
in dealing with the anxiety of life? Or like, what is what's? Well, just the.
Green stuff is weed. Well, just like, yeah. That's what I assumed. Um,
<laugh> <laugh> yeah. We'll just like call it what it's. Um,
yeah, it's, it's something that, you know,
it helps. And it also, like is,
is something that you can use for different things. It can, it,
it helped me learn how to meditate at first mm-hmm <affirmative>, you know,
it was a lot easier to smoke a little bit and then meditate than it was to just
go in without, with just like the most clear mind. It,
it helped me build a relationship with meditation to where I don't need it to
meditate anymore. You know, there's, there's things there's benefits to it.
And I think there's also just a,
a sense of security and knowing that, um,
that even if I'm having a bad night and I turn to that,
that's not going to kill me. Well.
You know, I guess you'd get there without weed. You.
Can. You totally can. Yeah. I just found that.
Like, weed gets you there quicker. Yeah.
<Laugh> just a little bit <laugh>. Um, and I just,
yeah, I there's.
It doesn't hurt you. That's the thing, it's like, it doesn't hurt your body,
but I do know people that have gotten to do to weed, you know? Yeah. And that's.
Something to be mindful of for sure. But.
I, I have, it's not a physical addiction though. It's not an addiction,
like alcohol or benzos or Coke or anything like that. Mm-hmm, <affirmative>,
it's a, it's an impulse, it's a psychological addiction. It's what it is. Yeah.
I mean, maybe for some people it's a physical addiction, like really,
really rare, but for most people there's no,
there's nothing happens when you get off it. There's no withdrawals. Yeah.
Yeah. I think that it's something to be like, mindful of just like
anything new in my life. I kind of,
I have a treatment team that I run things by. So you.
Run weed by them. Yeah. What'd they say.
Whatever, you know, I came out of, I went to treatment for like a relapse.
I relapsed in, uh, 2019 and it was heavy and it was a heavy.
One. Yeah. Explain to everybody what you went through, cuz it's like, you,
it sounds normal, but you almost died. So.
I overdosed on heroin and crack.
That was well, the heroin was laced with fentanyl and, um,
I ODed in 2018 and
that experience was a near death experience for me.
The doctors told me I had five to 10 minutes before it was too
late. Um, when they found me I was blue, I was,
there was blood and it was just, I had three strokes,
a heart attack and multiple organ failure.
And I still have brain brain damage from it.
And what kind of brain damage? So.
I have blind spots in my vision and I also had hearing loss from
everything. Um, the blind spots are like, like I don't, I don't drive.
Um, I can't, unless I was on like an open dirt road and I could just like,
I just don't wanna put other people at risk on the roads. Um.
So you like, normally you see everything,
like you see everything in front of you right now.
No. So even like your face, I see your eyeballs. When I'm looking at your eyes,
I see your eyes, but I don't see your nose, your mouth, or even your microphone.
What do you see? This part?
It looks like I, I looked at the sun. Wow. You know,
when you're a kid and you look at the sun, cuz someone told you not to.
Cuz I'm that kid <laugh> <laugh>. Yeah.
It's like that. When you look at the sun and like, or, or even like a,
a camera flash and it kind of goes like greenish blue ish, it's not black,
but it's you can't see.
And it's just like a blind spot that takes over kind of like everybody's bottom
half of their face. Wow. And so my focus.
Could you focus on someone's bottom half of their face? If they were smiling,
could you look down at their teeth?
I have to look down at people's mouths when they talk. So you only.
See like a Stripe, like a, of their face. Yeah.
Literally just exactly where you put it. I could see the top of your fingers,
but not your hand. And so for the first few months,
like I couldn't read out of a book. Um,
I was so hard to like tweezing my eyebrows. Couldn't do that at first.
How do you live? Um, <laugh> how do you live? Exactly.
My browser extremely important to me. So that was a huge thing. Fabulous.
Thank you so much. I'll thank you. You're.
Doing a great job. Whatever you can see. Thank.
You. Uh, whatever you can see <laugh>
you're Savage. Oh my God. Um, but yeah, so there was things that, and,
and I had to ask like opinions on my outfit. Like I couldn't. Oh, wow.
Couldn't see what shoes went with.
My outfit. Is this getting any better?
No. So it plateaued after six months,
like whatever it would be after six months after the overdose would be what
it'll be for the rest of my life. And so, and.
This is from the stroke mm-hmm <affirmative>. Wow.
So this, this experience that you had,
you are, you, you had heart attack, you had strokes,
you have this vision issue that's gonna exist for the rest of your life.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> so I I'm sure everyone around you then was like, Hey,
you gotta stay the away from all drugs forever. Like this is it. I,
we almost lost you. Yeah. This could be it for your life. Mm-hmm <affirmative>.
So how do you, how do you ease in a weed from.
There? So it's, it took a lot of time. Um.
What was the impetus? Like what, what led you to do it?
Um, what led me to do it actually was I got into recovery from my
bulimia and I thought, all right,
this is an addiction I've had since I was 12.
How is it that everything started at 12 for me, I was like,
how is it that I finally found recovery from this?
But yet I'm still struggling with substances. I thought, well,
what am I I doing with food? That's different.
And I wasn't looking at it from a dogmatic approach,
this all or nothing mentality. You know,
I was eating taco bell and letting myself keep it down and not throwing
it up anymore. And that to me was a new,
the normal person. Like doesn't know that,
that of course that's what you do with taco bell. You, you let it sit.
This was a new idea for me. I like, my mind was blown.
You would eat, you would go on a bend or eat taco bell and then just like, okay.
Out of the pool, boys black.
Pretty much. Yeah. Pretty much.
Every time you ate something terrible like that, you knew that you were gonna.
Throw it up. Yeah. Yeah. And, um, so when I,
when I went,
after I had relapsed in 2019 on the hard stuff,
um, I went back to the treatment center, had gone to right after,
uh, treatment. And I just said to them,
I was like, I,
I think I need to allow myself the ability to really try
this middle path. And not like before,
when I said I was on a middle path, but really was like,
and was like really trying to party. Like I'm, I mean, like if I wanna smoke,
then I'll let myself smoke. And I just,
I kind of came to terms with,
I kind of came up with that and talked it through with my treatment team back
home and let everyone know like, Hey, this is, I have to,
to own my truth. And um, and my treatment team said, okay,
like we'll support you and stand by you.
What do you need from us that will help. And it was at that point that like,
I started getting this thing called the Vivitrol shot, which is, um,
a shot that blocks all the opiate receptors in your brain.
Know if, I mean, honestly,
even if I were to get in like in a bad injury and go to the hospital,
I couldn't even get opiates in a hospital because like my body
will reject them so much. It goes into withdrawals immediately. Really? Yeah.
And then, but, but.
Why do you need that?
Um,
so F it also helps with bulimia because what people don't realize about bulimia
is that it helps, um, bulimia. When you throw up your opiate receptors,
go off in your brain.
So sometimes people actually get addicted to the high you get
after throwing up, rather than like,
people think that it's like,
there's act actually a physical component in your brain that people get addicted
to. Um,
and that's why people become addicted to the feeling that euphoria after
you.
That's crazy. I had no idea. I thought it,
you always felt every time I've thrown up, I'd felt terrible.
I never would've imagined there's so.
I guess, because you're sick. Yeah. I think like, if you're not sick,
maybe you don't feel tear. I don't, I don't under, I don't know.
But now I'm thinking of trying it. No, no, no, no, my God, no, no,
I'm.
Kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. Listen. Okay. I'll never be believing. I,
I eat like a pig.
And that's okay.
It's okay to eat like a pig. Thank you.
Yeah. If that's, what if that's what makes you happy then?
Like own your truth and live it. Right. You.
Know? So I, I'm still curious as to like,
what a about weed made.
You want to even introduce it into your life after working so
hard to be sober and having this horrible experience with overdosing.
Right. So I dealt, I often say,
and this is really hard for people to hear sometimes,
but I think that drugs saved my life at times because
had I not had something to medicate with, I wouldn't be here.
I would've taken my life by now.
I've dealt with suicidal ideation since I was seven years old.
And that's just something that's always been a part of my journey.
I don't know why, but depression is, I've been, I've had a journey with that.
Um, there was a period of time where I thought to myself,
I'm so miserable. I'm still sober. Now I'm sober again.
This is after the overdose. I'm so sober
and still so unhappy. What am I doing?
And I got to this place where I kept thinking
if I pick up, you know, that term, um,
I had been told so many times by people in recovery or treatment team,
whatever, not this treatment team,
but a different one that if I picked up that I would die. And I,
I thought to myself,
what kind of life? Um,
am I living? If I'm miserable 24 7?
And if I feel like the bottom is gonna drop out, I'm gonna die.
Like that's not really a life to live. And so I thought,
what if there's some sort of relief in between? That's not gonna kill me.
That's not, um, that's not,
I don't know, super dangerous. You know, what is it? And I thought, well,
I live in California. <laugh>, you know, why not a little weed?
And so I tried it and it wasn't so bad.
And I began to appreciate what it could do for me.
It stopped me from going to the other thing,
a lot of people say that weed is a gateway drug,
but what people don't know is that it can also be a
drug that can provide a little bit of relief for people who feel like
when they get that low, they're either gonna pick up something really dark,
really heavy or something,
more ominous, you know, take, yeah, I don't.
Buy that gateway.
I don't either. I really don't. And if Don, I don't buy it with anything also,
I hate even calling weed a drug because it's a sacred plant,
like it's sacred medicine.
And so talking like a healer.
<Laugh> I am, I am, but it, but it is.
It's like it's under the category of sacred plant medic.
Medicine. So there's, there's definitely some magical properties to it.
Catch new episodes. The Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data cost. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.